hello welcome another
daily appointment for the press online
live on ovs today is
Wednesday January 6th
today we have news on
our support for small and medium
-sized enterprises and start-ups so I'm
speaking directly  to johannes
on this subject uranaise thank you very much
hello everyone the turn to
conclude but for lack of enrique newcastle
and I pass the floor to christian
I can ask the first question it's
a question for peter stein and it
relates to the wave of  arrests in flip flops
of 53 pro-
democracy opposition figures were arrested in hong
kong
sweden's foreign minister van hamme and dine de said she was
very concerned so i would like to know if
you have any reaction to  this decision
of the chinese authorities and more for you
eric on december 30 the european union
signed a pre agreement with china for
the protection of investments
i would like to know co  How do you react
to the critics who say that in fact
the European Union eases its
conscience by talking a lot about the
values ​​of democracy and
human rights but that in fact there is not
much behind it that follows that it  is
in fact this agreement it is a kind
of blank check that was given to the
repressive policy of beijing so
these two criticisms that I read
today just after the announcement of
this wave of arrests I want
know how you react
thank you thank you christian I pass the floor
to heaps thank you hello and of course but
that's another reaction
the coordinated arrest of more than 130
pro democracy activists 1 on
charges of subversion based on the
law on the  national security sends a
signal what a problem political realism
is no longer tolerated in hong kong
the national security law is being
used to crush dissent and
stifle the exercise of
human rights and
political freedoms  ues who are protected by the
basic law of hong kong and also by
international law and international obligations and
commitments of china
so we as the european union
call for the immediate release of
those arrested
thank you thank you very much i the criticisms
you referred to
christian we saw them one
it's not that today there have
already been some
the days go by and and as you know
we have already responded to these
criticisms explaining that this is not the agreement
that we  have signed on
investments which is the
appropriate tool to deal with the relationship with
a country which is a complex country and
therefore also with which we have
complex and
multidimensional relations and therefore we have
a sectoral agreement in the field of
investments which aim  to ensure
that european investments in china
are as protected
as chinese investments in europe and
that our access  es to the chinese market from this
point of view there is either fair but
we have of course a whole other
policy in matter and another
dialogue with china with
regard to the rule of law and
democracy and peter has already had the
many times to
explain our position to you in this area
and he has just explained our
position in relation to the
Chinese decisions that have been taken recently
so it is clear that we work
with China in a different way on
different dimensions
we have  for example the
climate dimension we have already had the opportunity
to read here on many occasions the
president also how important it was
to work with a country
like china in this in this area
there in other areas we
are  economic competitors of
economic partners
and that is indeed why
we have this agreement this draft agreement
on investments and there
are  other dimensions such as, of
course, the primordial one of human rights
and the rule of law for which we
have a specific dialogue with
china and specific instruments
falot and christian
yes but what can you
tell me what are  the
specific instruments and for peter i know that the
last general affairs council
mr borel had been questioned he
had not ruled out the possibility of
sanctions after indeed that we had
asked for the release of a certain
number of militants from hong kong who
been imprisoned release which
still has not been obtained almost a month
later and so sometimes I wonder if
the appeals are actually
heard and if all this is not a
kind of fool's game which makes us not
you will never have any results understand you
will not have to do mercantilism and that
human rights will remain
something that we will forget as quickly as we
will have spoken about it thank you on the instruments I
pass  e la parole à pitre thank
you christian thank you christian of course men we
discussed healthy subjects in the
last foreign affairs council in
december and we also discussed the
implementation of the holy
national security laws which is very
controversial which is a source  of
screen concerns concern for the european union i
would like to call that the ministers for
foreign affairs of the member countries have
underlined that the political
situation has deteriorated taking into account
serious attacks on political
pluralism freedom of opinion and we have also
confirmed that the european union will
continue to implement the
conclusions expressing political support
for the autonomy of hong kong
under the principle one country two systems
is necessary if necessary other measures
can be considered or riom i
would also like to remind that  we have already
started with one of the juliet measures
when we decided to introduce
specific measures as a response to the imposition
of  the national security law in
hong kong
these measures
concerning asylum
policy emigration policy devising and residences
exports of
specific sensitive technology equipment
for end use
in hong kong is also a town its
scholarship  university exchange for
students and for the union for the
universities we count is also
commitment and will support for civil society
we count of course the situation
it is a source of concern we follow
the european union the institutions
the member countries follow very
carefully antenna carefully
negative developments
she we are going to react the analysis is in
progress she we can also
use other measures such as sanctions
you have even if we are but for this
process I would also like to remind you that
it is a process that requires the  nanny
the unanimity of the european
nano union a unanimous decision of all
member countries and after  nce an analysis of the
development situation we will
reflect on which are the best which
are the measures which are the best
measures to take in order to react she has
the next opportunity
in addition to the discussion which are
not short now the next
opportunity to discuss a  some
thing these topics these
high level developments will be the foreign affairs council
has a this is me in a few
few weeks thank you very much are there
any other questions about china for
peter prison and which will take effect as soon as in
china
david yes thank you  to stop taking
thing I would like to express my regret
for the fact that there was no
press conference after the announcement of
the agreement with the machine for the two
times we cannot question the
presidency of the  commission and therefore the
political level that not the source
of the commission who technically explains to us
what is happening that says
like peter remind china has violated
it is not re  spected its
international commitments on hong kong
and I would like to know with regard
to the investment agreement
why you expect it to
also respect the commitments which are made
in this agreement in principle
since we have seen it throughout the  year
2020 china has not respected other
agreements for example with australia and
the imposition of customs duties
are you confident that
china respects the agreement in principle that
it has signed with you thank you  david
on the mechanisms that are included in
the agreement to ensure of course its
proper execution I give the floor to
myriam yes thank you
hello indeed we have in the
investment agreement with release the
dispute resolution mechanisms
as we know the  same as in
other trade agreements known in
third countries
so we have the possibility of
appealing to a court which could
give reason to the six never china does
not respect the commitments may  s in
addition we negotiated with china
something that china has never done
with other partners
it is a mechanism that will make the
versailles at the political level on the sides
of the european commission it will be the
vice-presidents of large  kisses and from
the Chinese side it is for lévis first and
if ever there is a real problem we
will have seven rapid response mechanisms
within thirty days to meet and
for those trying to find a
solution then we remain confident that we
can resolve if  there are never
differences and with regard to
sustainable development where we also have
compromises on the part of china in
relation to labor law in relation
to the climate
we also have a
mechanism with a panel of experts if
ever china  not respecting the
commitments of the agreement so we think
that we have all the means to really
do everything necessary if ever there are
7 macs of application of the agreement thank you
yum are there any other questions of
rela  international tions
for peter today this battling the
stick to international fadi chamoun
network equipment collects a
stronghold where philippe philippe piat the
floor yes hello philippe rené joined in
the evening if concerning neighboring countries of
china vietnam on this subject there we  there are
indeed some instruments
also there is a free
trade agreement which has been concluded with this country
we also have since the end of December
but it does not only concern the
detail of course but the whole world a
specific regime of sanctions
concerning violations of
human rights to play whether these
instruments could be
implemented in the case of vietnam where i
read well petter's scathing statement
this morning on the arrest of
three journalists
sentenced to extremely heavy prison sentences
quite simply  express their opinions
is what one might wonder if
these instruments that are at our
disposal would not be  not
currently usable in this context here
is what you can say about it
thank you thank you eh I will first give
the floor to [ __ ] possibly a
complement of myriam if necessary peter
thank you philippe thank you made the banjos yes
eh you have there
the statement we released on
the arrest and sentencing of the
three journalists in vietnam is a
very very negative development and
we call on the
vietnamese authorities to release all
people who are arrested for the
expression comes down from his opinion  on
the aim on the measures on the next
action
we have an established dialogue with
vietnam and we are trying to find the
solutions for this problem within the
framework of this engagement of this dialogue of
which that is a preferred option
sanctions are always only one
instrument to sanction it are
not objective are not the goal
therefore if is necessary and if there is an
agreement between the member countries  have
also been able to use the sanctions this
is the reason why we
designated implementation of the system where the
global system of the sanctions regime
against the high-speed line to do so violations of the
rights of donations for the for the
proposal of sanctions it is  an
initiative that can be the initiative of the
member countries this point can be an
initiative the proposal of the
representatives but as I say one of the
people in my answer to christiane the
process of the masters the procedure 1 and
must be preceded by a
deep analysis and we do the  analysis we must
also discuss among the member countries
to see if there was a consensus
for the sanctions because one thing to
make a proposal is that there
is no chance for one to have a
unanimous adoption or  so we have to
discuss first mom all the
processes on sanctions on an eos
including one that may or may not be
considered for sanctions and
confidential so we are working of course
it is a  domain we discuss we analyze
we in the exchanges between the
member countries to find the best way
to draw up and get up all these
problems to all is partner is
not only there
in vietnam but we are engaged in
the discussion and analysis with the  member countries
we are trying to find the solution the
best solution the best
solution
because like Thursday the sanctions are
the instrument but they are not an
objective thank you quickly I was going through it
myriam to complete the answer if
necessary yes thank you at just would like
bought only the free trade agreement and
a link with the political agreement which
goes klaus of human rights and
it is also an essential element of
the trade agreement
that means that if there had been a
serious violation  and systematic
human rights in these cases in
vietnam is the clause also applies
in canes with other
partners
we could possibly suspend the
preferences  commercial but it is a
mechanism of last resort
how peter also explained for
human rights and we first try
to find other solutions in
discussion with sounds good
damien but we always have our
possibilities of suspending the  the
sannois philippe trade agreement just a
small clarification to ask petter
can you also say
about vietnam as you did
for china that the next
opportunity to discuss it concretely
and in depth is indeed the
next university on January 25th I [ __ ] think let's
go of course it's possible
if there is an agreement between the member countries
cash is subject must be discussed in
the high level so we can we can't
discuss it in the foreign affairs council
but  as I say there has already been
discussion of a cerdane of the different
areas and levels of the
European Union on all the subjects
beginning with the with our
delegation on the spot with the packs
the embassies of the member countries there
are discussions in brussels in
the political and
security committee so there is a lot of
commitment is so high if there is an
agreement between the member countries quay on this
subject of these particular is managed  in
this particular country must be
discussed in the council so there is
no problem to put that we add to
thank you we continue on foreign affairs
I pass in time the mira
mirabelle you know it seems what they
refuse in cannes specific  we love
title no the site with a comeback character
the humira hockey mike swick go to hell and
not for once only do the friend
jacques pitoux sudden specificity this
match without a spectator knew
territories anfield
hockey scope hockey the stick  to action china
this weekend
beaten there is a colleague who have
both been suspended
committee chairman for other
causes like charles darwin quite
typical minus 25 matches
anna freud y  understood van sant 2-0
this weekend at thônex coliche meeting in
a full house and do they
strike artists as very specific and to al quds
the town hall told me jane lynch 2 dog days
after back to goal or not the
formulations have  right to go back to me
mira hockey and rim proposals nbc
national assembly an assembly
if stéphane seductive say to each other a taxi
where is this a peter ovidiu from riesener
enjoy the first 5
peter hayes six months
this we go to mathieu yes hello I
m'  i heard yes happy new year i wanted to
come back to venezuela
so i read the statement correctly
but do you support
juan garrido's approach which consists in
ensuring institutional continuity
by maintaining the national assembly in
place in parallel with the new one which
is this time controlled by the power
of my
[ __ ] pain thank you matthew i would just like to
repeat that i say that written
in the statement that we will
maintain our engagement with
partners in venezuela
democratic partners for us wang wei
whose other national assembly representative
who was elected in 2015 are
the partners for for committed
because the new national assembly
is not rewarded by us so the
partner the partner for  our
commitment in this area the partner
who represent the national whole
is the cold banter of the other
representative
adc assembly which was the lady 2015
but as I say also ahead the
discussions between the member countries on
the situation in the development in the
venezuela continues and we are going to discuss
it in the next few days 1 week in
our approach on venezuela
the impossible but if I do not see any more
hands raised with regard to
questions on external relations
we will therefore close this chapter has
moved on to  other questions and I see
radio luxembourg
yes hello
hello thank you happy new year again from
me I have a question about vaccines
rather on the contracts that the
commission has concluded with companies
you have said on several occasions I believe
that the member states have
undertaken not to conclude contracts
at national level with companies
in fact I wanted to know what
exactly is the  nature of this commitment
and what is the consequence in the event that
a country does not respect this commitment
thank you I do not think that is
exactly what we said but I will
pass the floor to stéphane to provide
more details on this point thank you
very much  for this question it is true
that when we adopted the
strategy
one of the key principles is to
work together to organize the
negotiations in a joint way and
the objective is where the philosophy or the
advantages are very clear when
working  together
we represent the market of 450
million people and the market of
27 member states
so that gives me a much
more important position.  nt within the framework of these
negotiations
in addition it avoids any kind of
competition between the member states
concerning the back of the amounts of doses
the crisis and celadon
the basic principle is to work
together
this this basic principle of
joint work and to avoid  of
parallel negotiations is a principle that has
always been strongly welcomed,
I would say at the
political level, whether at the level of
heads of state or at the level of the council,
but it is also a principle that has been
applied in the case of negotiations
even with  the different companies of
axa is therefore it is a principle that we
apply it is a principle that is
explained in this vaccine strategy
and it is a principle that has received the great
south supports support from
member states thank you very much thank you I  see who is
a question of follow up
yes thank you so if I understand correctly
there is no commitment let's say in writing
or concrete and not ten years ago
it is a country do not respect  this
agreement says in you talked about
working together
there are no consequences in any
country you can still change your mind and
conclude a contract as besides I
believe that germany has done it we do not lose our
shares
of the charge bought together
for example I'm not at
all sure that germany concluded a
contract appears what is clear is
that from the moment the states
had committed themselves throughout the  phase
of the negotiations not to negotiate a
contract in parallel he obviously had
an obligation to do so there is a
principle of loyal cooperation which
applies from the moment we
initiate a process
now I don't know if
later on after the  conclusion of a
contract there may be more more
flexibility his fans no that's
absolutely absolutely right eric i would like to
point out that all ai all
member states indeed also underlined their
support for this strategy  as part
of a co  nvention concluded between the
commission and the member states in
which it agrees on seven
basic principles these key principles
which form the basis of
this strategy and which call for a
joint approach to the negotiations
thank you let's stay on the question so
vaccines real life vaccination are there
any other questions on the subject marco
pressure' vaccine you can hear me
we are trying so go ahead
and there is a certain disconnection
november 5 the coalition forces commission
we must not throw everything at the top  carrying
a media elisor the style of
discs sculpin thousands of other
systems in place and contextor of
discs h inscriptions explains one of the
accomplices rigor of the channels and rule out
a place unprecedented rigor of the
overdose game all the same took a
installation tour of  hopeful systems
to save steve squyres linde
context as prestigious
2 million euros in
commissions our language of
communication  we deserve to be far from
boxes with abu de grimm concludes die
den mosquito nets yes yes and cindy
commissions did that in september
sobrino consequentialist in the fig
marc durst stéphanie the queen basseng
date of this cash in context of the bike
situation say what  doing explains this
context and overpriced assets with
sid strategy michel pauly by christian
reynders no fuss indeed howard
negotiations
maxim vaccination all the demonstrations 10
own climate who takes risks
and what to do china concerns vaccine
vaccination tribute to the yukon people
reaction when bindi  nigeria a
correct agreement english in the context of
security committee yes
a tony scott and schultz bruises de douce
france to set the prices with 115 and
here chooses 10.6 at the security committee
meeting fascination prince high school dc
comics the specific characteristics
context the context and the  national life
context here we go
the canada tour in 2010 our 2000
da  te to saint avold privacy
key word stand star including but
stop breeders of dogs cats
birds vaccine boiler room reduced
prince who touches me
robin to discussions regarding cindy
schmidt be a good to great eastern plays
in this context and nico rosberg is
level  6 or 5 contract for ever had to
play 102.5 mile catwoman dated a
at high vienna in trees aims 10
wright what they did against
all news corp indeed company
we have background negotiations
cries 5 dates  of these printing presses complex
operation
yes complex ouisme in contact with success
this vaccine vaccinations and production
capacity of odors and logistics on the
contrary it was distribution
fortis
johnny to the sky with the company is
one day unemployment
she digs hairdressing the role of
leader state  and corrections of
ligocyte in disney as rich
and innocence ricouart at the stadium of france
johnny nocentini jalil also sung to the
brain mam s'es  t moreover written
dhoinine at the scouts headquarters of the facsimiles
not said jones nino cerruti report to the
same sex funny of this terrible story
of all styles of jazz by django
systematics carried out in 2009 in order
for you to i want is the vaccine this
[ __ ] 1  ,2 to be green grid to reflex names
facing stéphane rossini is requested 100
is gonna come in particular a sum
they exclude miniou technology
domestic life context mix to
commission sales and member states to
gather means we are out
at about  that so come back of the
world ceding assets and the context of
means that of an unworthy exit
concedes goals and shirt open to this
content
francesco
[Music]
ning mountain tech builds seems to be the
additional  additional of triangle
millions nba
agri referred to as morane demont standing in
september 8 bayonne tech has been seen
as bricks lego ninjago fax vickerman
population and a person on if it's
tru  e north end at spa tens of
millions national
germany who died for and envy extra
september and if this match was against the
style it means to unwind left and dig
in parallel weeds bayonne tech has all the
same rock news and nights of
5 compared  of the sims bridge and the west
clarification germany in basel 10 vivendi
public states and also for the view
comment on ditexiste stephan agostini
balte nation germany's next big thing we
have that we have de ce cast we can be
distributed to members scoring qui a
thing  we stéphanoise kevin grevioux
daughter
express let's continue to fail there
also love between david and senator
from isère the grid but something else
next to you from six young people in god or not
from vaccines
an inconvenience commission n 10 even the
states  porcine obligation to negotiate
this part and Cévennes articles so
it's not de standing 12.6 valette ten
faults or a devil is closed ken back
bay the tradition with company solitude
and diddy diddy  of the desperate president the
company so we would like to know what
do you do
description 5 david newell squash 1822
scratching numerous sites and services
context of allowances explodes and
bring to be to be done by washington to
stéphane hannibal irene van persie
expectations 8 tsunami  things
world sandor has known expresses everything me
what gonna be from times square
yves desmet from greenlight to manado six
belgo french music the two toro
rosso
if the left is in a position
can you play on gross debt and his
table men and confess direct
wonderstone below if one member states
is so and critics on March 10 title
still s2 theoretical off option to go by
emergency
specific authorization begins in
left ardenne and jean sabine club de la
venise de street view once again will
negotiate
we have known for being so
ten of these young tennis players league
organizes this activity indicates a
chaste life photo stéphane heulot in marseille
vivaux specific this po  ste it is
difficult to negotiate but germany on
the wii controller
[Music
] indiscretions do do do bite
bright eyes in a move to yanis
initial self so serious problem if you're my so
sz so what it right out
we pass  in virginia
yanis yanis groupe ford
we are managing yes ben faiza concerning
life option d'isly to stéphane hessel
yes it's 2010
billington when a section out or in
loket life wang min china this weekend
only a shooting three extra numbers of
the witch clients going to which we hope
to bill gates of two days of night
virginie you asked to speak
on vaccines too can you
hear me we can hear bonhomie a
so hello me i have several
questions you about lyontech pfizer
you said that the first 200
million other plants and order
firm way had to deliver here September 21
I refuse that the additional 100 million
it's the same that she
works already after I would like to know it's
t out of the 200 million doses have
been firmly ordered
the twenty seven member states we can
buy because I understand
that this is not the case then the 30
million new doses that
your Germany so there I agree  the
question my predecessor but I did not
quite understand the answer I am confused
I thought I understood that it was 30
million doses were out of the 100
million endowments that we raised I
would like to check this point there and to
in general
I would like to understand how you
explain that the m&a in you are going to
say to me you have to ask the m&a but hey
all the same it concerns you a little bit
take more time than its
Israeli American counterparts
I will not talk about the British
since I know  that they have adopted an
emergency procedure to authorize the
basins
here you go thank you virginie I give the floor
to stéphane verger hello there are
several questions there firstly with
regard to the delivery of  7,300
million doses the 200 million
doses indeed we were all planned to be
free and therefore the distribution has already
started now it puts so all
the doses will be delivered by the end of
September 2021 while the doses of
100 million additional
this delivery  could probably take place
later in the year
that's a first thing with
regard to the purchases that are made
by the member states
comerica explained of which we concluded
our our framework contract and it is up to
the member states
indeed now  what has been done
what is in the process of placing their orders
with the companies for ordering and
delivery of doses and in the case of
these contacts
obviously the member states and the
companies agree on their right
reason for the places the  name etc
it makes perfect sense because the
member states are responsible for
their vaccination campaigns and all
this work is going on with the member states
the third that  stion it's 30
million doses yes indeed when we tried
to
explain according to our understanding the
discussion on these 30 million takes place
within the framework of the discussions on the
additional 100 million or so at this
stage if the member states  a right on
what basis we can ensure a good
distribution taking into account the
needs of the member states finally by
financing the hands your question
is why does emma need
more time than what the counterparts
I think I  should point out that
emma has greatly accelerated the procedure
by introducing what are called
rollers a review the purpose of these roles
reviews yields already carried out an in-
depth analysis of the companies' data
even before the companies submitted an
application for authorization to  placing on the
market and therefore it allows the state to
do a very great job of analysis
before the introduction of this official request this
is what has been done with
faes library for example  emple a role of the
wolf was started well before the
request
for authorization and emma made a
decision within twenty days of
this request
I would also like to emphasize that the
work that was done by me is a
very broad work that goes  in depth
because the purpose of this evaluation by
the masses is to ensure that the vaccines
are safe and effective
it is a main element of our
strategy but it is not enough just
to produce vaccines it is necessary that
this vaccine is really safe and
meets all the safety criteria
the ema assesses a whole series of
criteria to do this and for example
it also looks at the production processes
when there is still a difference between
producing only thousands of vaccines
in the context of clinical trials  and
iron and fire
production of hundreds of millions of
vaccines that are also needed in this
context, we have the necessary guarantees of
safety and effectiveness and therefore the hands
make a  in-depth analysis in detail
of all these elements to ensure
that vaccines are safe and effective
because it is important to be able to
demonstrate to our European citizens that
it is important that they take this
rac as they please and vaccinated thank you for the
zeniths usa europe
I wanted to know it's about the 200
million doses all the member states
the 27 member states
how I was told that a turnip several
who finally didn't want the
finder I speak initially I speak
not today but therefore if all the
member states
I could have thought if all the
member states had said that they wanted to
order vaccines from pfizer first
question second question if I come back
to the m&a I know all that the ruling
rovio  thing etc but but
what does that mean what does that mean that for example the
Israeli authorities where the authority
the Israeli or American counterpart of
the ema does not make the same analysis kit
for that they want faster and
for  what
astrazeneca has not yet
applied for authorization from the
orchid possibly authorized I do
not quite understand anyway
despite everything you explain to me I do
not understand it is not very serious a
few weeks but as it is  is as
if one of the angles of attack
against europe and against the m&a on this subject
there I try to understand why the
m&a goes longer lows more slowly than
the others nevertheless virginity
questions are perfectly justified
with regard to the  differences of
two times that are taken by
different institutions to do
their analysis and evaluation of a
vaccine but you understand that these are
really questions that we
would prefer that you ask in detail to the
agencies concerned we cannot
here on  the podium give you a
detailed analysis of each difference in the
process in the prerogatives also
in the constraints that weigh on
each of the American European institutions
' were etc
we know the hands can
certainly explain its process very well
but we are not going to
comment we have no analysis available to
us here to to compare
to make a comparison between the
different between the different
national authorities what  account and it
must be remembered what has always
mattered from the beginning is that
we had to make sure that the vaccines
were safe and effective because it
was considered rightly and it
should continue to be considered
rightly as a  essential precondition in
order to guarantee
the acceptability of vaccines by the
European population
and it is all the same a certain paradox
that even though this has been the
major concern throughout the summer
and we have had a lot of questions
that you  have addressed in the world
question to the m&a on it now
suddenly everyone turns around
saying but how come you
are two weeks co  llet me either two
weeks or three weeks slower than
another another institution
what is clear is that this is not
a shallot race
it is a process that must ensure that
the vaccination process in  as a
whole is crowned with success and the
confidence that citizens have in the
work that is being done by the
European Medicines Agency is an
essential element in this in this debate, so
that is what we
believe we need to focus on  and less about
the fact that it takes two weeks
more or weeks or weeks of
months than in another institution
of course it is legitimate to
wonder to what extent the
different institutions work in
the most efficient way possible
you know  that from this point of view we
have made great efforts, including at
the European Commission,
to speed up the process where it
could be
from an administrative point of view in order to be
able to obtain  r on the one hand an opinion of the
mba is that when it was
positive then a marketing by the
european commission a factor for example that
characterizes us here in the european union
is the  multilingualism is
something we have been working on these
are the rules in terms of information
on the packaging etc etc
so there is a whole series of variables
which obviously varies from one
geographical entity to another there
were  there another question stéphane
I hope that if there was another
follow-up question that you
can answer yes I think there was
before the question on the state of the purchases
of the etam in all the first  delivery
of the place already on December 26 as you
know it's all member states to place
their orders but there are several orders
that can be done it's a process
with several beautiful things
so from what we understood the
all  others have displaced e  n
regards to the December mode but it is
a process that is ongoing
obviously if there are any
questions on the specific delivery
of some of some of the member states
I also advise you to
contact the member states  to follow
the state of the question in this case there
but it is a process which is in progress
that it is clear yes virginie thank you
for having rewritten your question
if I understand correctly it is the 27
are the  twenty-seven had
expressed an interest in the
negotiation to have the vaccine is what
they ultimately ordered us
in terms
of the contract negotiation process
it's not something we
're going we're going to get into  but what I
believe I can say, but subject to
verification, is that all the
member states then expressed their interest
in obtaining vaccines from the doses
of the bartech riser vaccine, it must not be
forgotten either once again that it
has  elapsed  tween the start of
negotiations and the conclusion of
contracts, a certain period of time during which
the understanding by the various
players of the technologies in question,
knowledge of the accounts of the companies
concerned, etc., has evolved, so what
counts is the final result, it is
good  this is why we have set up
a group including the member states in
order to be able to exchange information
dialogue between member states and with the
European commission in order to
ensure that the final contract the
purchase loan agreement that we have signed can
take into account the needs of each and
beyond the evolution of their
understanding
over the thread of the negotiation
it is now an hour and twenty
that we are here it is
with great pleasure but we will
end the 2010 conference at  1:30
coffee
[Music]
a cloudy executive is also seriously lacking this type of function
all all the left-handers dancing in his
zouaves, said m darc  os
when betty and that's what the climate
is their date vis pinch
info from the three kings narcos
thanks eric i'm sorry to bring
this up again on the same question but i
thought it was my fault i didn't  did
n't understand but I see that there are quite a few
colleagues who have their hands on
what I do and so I believe that you are
there to help us to make some
clarity and so I just wanted to
clarify from 3 poses the  question of the 30
million doses so if you of the clip
as you say but in millions of
doses that the government is talking about
are part of the 100 million doses
of options which the commission decided to
exercise this right at the end of December
I want  knowing so that means that
there is no bilateral agreement between
the German government and faïza
biotech because it is within the
framework of the agreement that the commission
had signed in November I want
to  first clarify that and second thing
if it's as you say po
why are we talking about 30 million doses and
not 18 million doses but that the
German population is 18% of the
European population
I know that we can have changes
some countries can have more doses
than their population but  that's part of
it must pass to an agreement between
member states
not by an agreement between member states and
the hall to the company that produces the
vaccine
so if you can clarify these two
points there you would really be
happy because I believe  that there are quite a few
colleagues who have not yet
understood this point we have been here for an hour and a
half but if after an
hour and a half we have not yet found
it means that
oh it  is our fault we do not understand
your box which did not lead to
explain this point thank you very much
thank you marco there is a 3rd option
obviously which is that you understand
very well but that you want
us to express in another way
so I'm going to come back  ur what I said
it is not we who are going to be able to tell you
if there is
on a desk somewhere in germany
1 a draft agreement memorandum of
understanding between germany and the
german authorities and the  company bec
faiza what we are saying is that our
understanding is that
today the discussions on
germany's additional needs
in terms of doses of balzac faiza
are taking place in the context of our european mechanism
that's the one and only thing
we said i didn't say there was
no draft agreement there is
no draft agreement between germany
bars and night  laugh what I said to
you what stéphane said is that the
discussions according to my
understanding according to our understanding which are
currently taking place on the
additional needs expressed by Germany
for doses of  vaccine in
the interface take place within the framework of the
European mechanism which was set
up to just  meet the
needs of the different member states
that's all we said
i think that's crystal clear
oliva
this fall
refer to be enough europe like in
france ex queer design 6 asamoah annan
propriano the resumption and as cliff lee
in the process as a misunderstood in subtlety
of what chemistry yade to the specific zaveri
one and i was to prove to be virginia
where she wants said she explanations astou
wider interpreter functions
between and i want and  to certain
number of over and linda context of
nantes
or then a work position or a
photo exhibition and new order
on sale or in a version so quite frankly
complicated she is fine which is a
myriad of skyscrapers miss france
yes but taiwan china woman virginia
guen we vaccinate them come back to you
pointe
virginie just said earlier that
the united states had ordered 200
million doses from yzeure and europe
300 but we're not going to have the numbers
res i saw because they are only 7 to
10 they have 200 million
firm orders and 500 million options and
we have 200 million forms and 100
million options
so i feel like  that we count
that in fact the states will deny so
ordered much more fader doses than us
in reality I was going through it
it was fala his part yes that him no I
think of the reason why I had
lifted this novel that  it's
because your colleague said that we only
had the united states had ordered I
think 6.6 million for 600
million doses I think it's not
yet which one I think the
united states will comment on 200  million and we
on our side are telling us that it is
quite possible that there are also options
but in I wanted to emphasize it is the
number of orders that have been placed
and on the side of the European union I have
underlined  that we placed a
giant order of 200 and then we
decided to exercise this option of 100
million  additional doses
thank you thank you i am now closing the
chapter on vaccines and we come
back to tod's question on
prices i think it's for myriam
hockey are covered false picture of
quintiles continues to drop to 101 5